we got one more relationship guys this
is uh adam from charlotte north carolina
this is adam coming for a relationship
i've met adam actually
what's up theo and brandon this is adam
coming from
charlotte north carolina got some
relationships north carolina ask
um recently been talking to this girl
that got out of a serious relationship
and uh
she come up she comes over a lot and
she cries a lot yup and
i've been trying to console her and try
to make her feel better
is her name
just a lot going on party hard brendan
who [ __ ] cries a lot because he's on
[ __ ] special medication for his
illnesses
i'm kidding bro or keep trying to
comfort her
but i kind of feel like a [ __ ] doing
that yeah i don't know if that's the
right move
i can relate to that you start a podcast
bro
that's all i can tell you or keep doing
what i'm doing
and you know i don't know if it's
working so
let me know what you guys think gang
bang bust nuts
another bust nuts and gang bang dude
shout out to this dude
if she's a constantly crying you got a
real debbie down on your hands
can't be that excited to see if she's
constantly crying to me when girls cry
it's kind of sexy kind of a turn-on
i don't know what that is probably
something my childhood i need to figure
out
talk to a therapist about but maybe i'll
talk to this guy about it
but she's constantly crying things ain't
going well man well salt water can give
you an erection dude i grew up around a
lot of brackish
flow myself brother nice saltwater croc
get me hard
um yeah what she's crying at the house
and he's trying to make the relationship
stronger she won't stop crying yeah they
she just got out of a relationship
and now she won't every time she hangs
out but she just cries the whole time
yeah then at this point it sounds like
you're just kind of going to be a buddy
you know like it for
for the for the seat for the real deal
for the stuff
um i think at this point maybe
you get a nice outfit
you know do something nice for yourself
buy yourself a nice hat buy yourself a
nice shirt
pair of jays uh no
brandon buy yourself a ca you know uh
cuff
cummerbunds get out there and look fresh
do something else bro you'd be
supportive of her but you can't be
her um you know yeah you're not a
therapist dude don't be a punching bag
you know what i'm saying
don't be the kleenex bucco
yeah [ __ ] man yeah man [ __ ] tired
good luck dude
but dude i love you man and um hope if
if listen
and god loves the cry baby don't work
out you'll find somebody else
yeah and it's nice that you you're
willing to be there for her for a while
uh yeah you're a nice guy man but just
don't be there forever dude you got [ __ ]
to do
too no one likes to cry baby you gotta
live your life yep
get her some dunkaroose tell her to shut
the [ __ ] up
we got something
this isn't your this isn't parenting
techniques okay
i was hoping you got that yeah i don't
know man just trying to liven it up up
in here
[Music]